the best tonic for the mess is to send
jacob to grom to the mount coming off
consecutive 14 strikeout performances
says brilliance has been on full display
right throughout his first few starts
and jake degrom so far this year with a
0.45 era
has struck out 35 and 20 innings andrew
stevenson leads off
and there strike three called a hundred
miles an hour over the inside
corner and stevenson caught looking
one up one down josh harrison will be
the banner
and he strikes out harrison and degrom's
got back-to-back strikeouts to start the
night
very tight slider ahead in the count
starts out in the strike zone
and then breaks down low and away
can't hit it it's not a stripe well here
is trey turner the outstanding shortstop
turner breaks his bat as he grounds one
to third jd davis on the move perfect
throw to get the speedy turner
and degrom has a 1-2-3 opening inning
now 28 year old right hander eric fenney
goes to work for the nationals making
his fourth start of the year one and one
record
5.56 cra facing brandon nimmo swinging a
ground ball right side second baseman
harrison has it
straightens and throws to bell at first
and nemo's out one away
so one up one down francisco lindor
coming up swinging a ground ball right
side
comes up on harrison of the midsection
fields it cleanly and the throw to josh
bell
to up two down on a couple of ground
ball outs for eric fenney and that is
normally
how fetty wants to have success in the
start swinging the ground ball right
side of the shift cut off by
the third baseman castro he'll throw to
bell for a 5-3 put out
it's a one two three inning taking the
drop through five pitches a hundred or
better
in the first inning josh bell leads off
and he blows away belle with a 100 mile
an hour fast ball and that's his third
strikeout
here's john gomes who's hit him well in
a very short sample
swing and a miss at a slider strike
three and that retires the side
four strikeouts four to ground the mets
get a lead off base runner
as alonso draws the wall and michael
conforto will be the banner find the
other way
and that's going to fall in for a base
hit alonzo the second he's gonna turn
in five for third winning throw by
schwarber on a hop
not in time aggressive base running by
alonso to go
first to third on the soft single by
conforto
and the mentor in business in the second
all runners at the corners for jd
davis he'd love one of those nine
strikeouts from his last start right
here right now
swinging in a foul tip it's held by
combs a big
strikeout of jd davis for the first out
of the inning for eric fetty
the chance maybe now to get out of the
inning unscathed if you can get mcneal
to hit a ground ball in turn two
that's a struggle to turn base runners
into runs it was a story last year it's
a story again this year
swinging the ground ball right side
harrison has it throw to second one
turn her back to first double play then
he gets the 4-6-3 twin killing
mcneal slams his batting helmet down
and the mets with first and third nobody
out failed to score
so degrom back to the mound with no
score victor robles leads off
and roblox goes around and he's a quick
strikeout victor for mcgraw but now has
five for the night
and 40 for the year they do men's club
record for
strikeouts and the first four starts of
a year swinging a missed strike three
fetty did his best strikeout number six
for jacob degrom against the first
nine batters that he has faced andrew
stevenson will try his luck with two
outs
center off nemo's glove deflects over
toward left center
and that will give time for stevenson to
motor into second little indecision
there by nemo
as to whether to let that ball drop or
come and get it
and i think it hit off the heel of his
glove washington with a man in scoring
position for the first time tonight
josh harrison grounds one right at
lindor and francisco takes care of that
to retire the side
six strikeouts in the first three for
degrom no score at city fields trey
turner will lead off the top of the
fourth against
jacob degrom has given up two hits
and the slider strikes him out
masterfully done by degrom for his
seventh strikeout over the first three
and a third
and he goes down on the changeup and
that's how degrom gets his eighth
strikeout
eight k's and four innings for the
degrominator
jacob degrom is strolling to the plate
now with runners at first and second one
out
in this scoreless game in the bottom of
the fifth and i think you could probably
read a thought bubble above the head
of jacob degrom right now if you want
something done badly enough you just
have to do it yourself
and he has a lot of the time he's
already four for eight this year
liner over third base head left field
the mets will take the lead
davis around third scores the grom on
its second
and you bet if you want something done
badly enough around here
you just have to do it yourself the
grump does with an rbi double
the mets mixer leading by a score of one
to nothing tomorrow he'll be taking
tickets
here's nemo's second and third two out
base it here's a back breaker
nemo grounds it to the right side past
the diving bell base hit right field
mcneil is in the ground coming to the
plate he'll score standing it's a
two-run single for brandon nemo
the mixer leading by a score of three to
nothing jacob degrom now with the lead
for the first time jordy mercer the
veteran
infielder will pinch it for eric fetty
leading off
and mercer goes down on strikes another
double-digit strikeout performance for
degrom the 49th
of his major league career and that
strikeout number 10 to start the sixth
inning here
who knows how many he'll put up if he
goes really deep into this one and
and stevenson down swinging at 100 mile
an hour gas
11 strikeouts for jacob degrom struck
him
out jacob de gramme struck out the side
in the sixth inning
and that's an even 12. a dozen
strikeouts for degrom
through six innings and it looks like
he's got a whole lot more in the tank
picasso has put down the pastels
and picked up the paintbrush gone back
to his studio
the pitching mound the canvas his rubber
and that's where he sets up shop to
begin the seventh inning jake gets him
for the second time
that's 13 for degrom 48 in his first
four start tying
a major league record he struck him out
14 for a third straight start
only the third pitcher in history to
strike out 14
batters in three straight starts pedro
martinez did it
in 1999 garrett cole did it in 2019
and now degrom has struck out 14 in
three consecutive starts he's also set a
record striking out 49 batters in his
first four starts of the year
and he's alone in that category is he
gonna do strikeout 300 this year
for a call strike three a career-high
15 strikeouts for jacob degrom
a master at the top of his craft camo
pulls in at second base with a
well-struck double
here's dominic smith there's a gem shot
shallow left falling fast
base hit around third nemo he's in the
score
and it's four nothing new york and here
comes degrom
how loud can 830 people sound
not bad and you could hear the mvp chant
a 1-1 line to right stevenson coming on
has to play it on a hop
it's a pace hit for degrom he is two for
two
he is six four eleven and this crowd
many of them are on their feet bowing
to degrom what else can you do
this is delirium here's nemo is that a
good night
breaking drill down the right field
[Applause]
brandon nemo with his first home run of
the year to put the icing on the cake
jacob degrom has three complete games
including one shutout in his major
league career who'll be bidding for both
tonight
jake's retired 16 in a row ground ball
toward the left side lindor
shuffles over then and throw right on
target
for the first down that is 17 in a row
set down by degrom
another chance for lindor and he makes
sure that one
18 in a row for degrom and the nats are
down to their final
out the mvp champ and he's one out away
from a complete game
shutout tapped on the ground alonzo to
his left
flipped to the ground and the ball game
is over
jacob degrom retires the last 19 batters
a two-hit shutout 15 strikeouts
no walks an unforgettable performance
for the master of his craft